[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cartel
non
que pensez vous du film quel film enfin
suis donc il est question ici à fiennes
à la suit là je suis là je crois que
c'est bon je dirais même que c'est très
bon pour l'instant on commence seulement
spécial extra spécial qu'il faut aimer
quoi
[Musique]
mais si on tombe bien alors que
pensez-vous du metteur en scène c'est
vrai mais bien c'est assez bon c'est
ouais c'est très bon face à sa mort est
bien c'est otto preminger godard cécile
2000e aimé lellouche réunis oui mais
même elle un peu spécial vous monsieur
vous les fait rentrer un parent récent
de prélats gérard entrant dernier du pro
d2 la pluie et auquel on peut rapidement
sorti une bombe sale va vous piquez la
bombe
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de falaise
fallait c'est bon je dirais même que
c'est très bon oui mais enfin ça
commence seulement
oui mais c'est bien c'est spécial oh la
balle et il faut s'habituer mais quoi
[Musique]
mais non
la voix reste dans les autres alors tu
passes avec ton par lui vous n'arrêtez
pas au pic d'abord appuyé l'idée d'un
vous savez la bombe ça non mais vous lui
tendez la nous et tendez pas il doit
fêter cela en la montrant avec les
résistants fit aussitôt prades vidéo
très bientôt et les charges aux acteurs
de cinéma à les charlots acteur de
cinéma c'est bon t'es toujours c'est bon
même très bon c'est même très très bon
ok très spécial oh là là oh la la c'est
bien mais y en a oui mais quoi ça allait
comme précision
libre
[Musique]